Mass evacuations are underway from Sudan
as the latest cease
fire agreement is set to expire in
just hours.
But some people who are desperate
to flee remain
of course, trapped, both foreigners
as well as Sudanese
with fighting like this
in Khartoum's densely
populated neighborhoods.
It is just too dangerous to stay
but it's also dangerous to leave.
And even once people manage
to reach safe,
safer ground,
their traumatic ordeals
are not necessarily over.
Our next guests
say his parents escape the horrific
fighting only to find themselves
in a desperate situation.
The Egyptian border.
Emara is a US citizen.
He and his wife
Leila are joining us from San Francisco.
Imad and Leila,
thank you very much to you
both for taking the time
to speak to us this evening in March.
Just just bring us up to date.
Where is your father right now?
Right now
they are currently in the RG,
a border on the Egyptian side
They are currently stuck.
They can't get into the country.
The Egyptians are denying
my father access
to enter Egypt
so he can come back to America.
And why are they denying him entry?
Because your mother,
from what I understand,
your mother can get can go through.
Right.
Yes, my mother can go through.
She's an American citizen.
She has a valid U.S.
passport in Iraq
while they were fleeing Khartoum,
you know, fleeing the bombing
and heavy shelling
My father lost
his valid American passport
and he didn't know it
until he got to
the Sudanese Egyptian passport.
But what he did have
was his expired
American passport
and a photocopy of his valid passport.
And that was not enough to allow him
entry into Egypt.
And they've been stuck at the border
for the past two days.
The conditions at the border
are extremely dire.
It's very hot.
They didn't have water, no food.
It's a humanitarian crisis.
That's breaking out in the corner.
And we are extremely worried
about my parents like they did.
You know,
we don't want them to escape
the atrocities
that are happening in Khartoum
just to die in the border,
trying to enter and flee
and come back home to us.
And he's 74.
And with the heat and the conditions
and the lack of water as you were saying,
that is incredibly worrying.
So just talk us through the efforts
that you've been trying to get through
to trying to get them out.
Who have you spoken to?
Who have you contacted?
We've contacted everyone that we know
that is able to influence the decision.
We've contacted the consulate in Egypt
on numerous occasions.
We've contacted the State Department
multiple times.
We've contacted
our local congressman
here in San Francisco as well.
We are doing everything in our power
to see if we can make a change
and see if we can.
They can allow my father to enter.
We just need him to enter the country.
So he can come to America.
It doesn't make sense to turn him away.
Now, if they've come so far,
just to be told that they cannot enter
is frankly unacceptable.
And it's appalling.
Your contacts, the
State Department,
what are they telling you?
What is the US side
saying in terms of what they can do
The US says they're trying their best.
They're trying
to communicate with the embassy, but
we're not getting a status update
There's no transparency into the process.
We've asked them all
times, like, you know what,
how long this is going to take.
What are the steps that you're taking?
Even if you were to get approval.
How are you going to contact
our parents on the ground?
You know, it's hard to get
cell phone service
you can to connect with them.
So everything has been up in the air.
And frankly,
super confusing
for us as much as our parents
who are on the ground trying to survive.
And imagine,
Leila, I mean,
when was the last time
you spoke to a father?
What conversation? What did he tell you?
What what did he sound like?
Demand.
He he sounded extremely anxious,
deeply worried
that he might not be able to make it.
He says the conditions there are dire.
There is no food.
He cannot take his medicine without food.
You know, he has a health condition,
a heart condition,
diabetes, high blood pressure.
Him and my mother are struggling
right now.
They're just in shock
that they're not able
to enter the country.
And they sound very desperate.
They are very desperate right now.
And your mother can cross this
of course, I'm guessing here.
He doesn't want
she doesn't want to leave him.
It's hard to leave a loved one.
You know,
it is hard to leave a 74 year
old man by himself.
In these conditions.
So you're in a situation
where really, both yourself
and your wife, Leyla,
you kind of hitting your head
against the wall.
So what is your message
here to the State Department?
Our message to department is to
please help our fellow citizens
out, allow these Americans
to enter the country
so they can seek aid, they can seek help
so they can leave Egypt.
Our objective is not to stay in Egypt.
We want to bring them back home.
These are American citizens.
We should do everything in our power
to ensure that they're able
to come back home
and help us
and also to explore
ways to cut the bureaucracy.
We're just trying
to understand how hard it is to contact
the border,
to just communicate
that he has a valid passport.
So bureaucracy, we can't kill our family.
And we're asking for assistance
for those on the ground,
for water, food, basic necessities.
We understand
UNHCR and others
might be working
to visit the border,
but we're hoping they can act sooner.
And provide desperate supplies
as soon as possible.
It's an incredibly worry for his health
and for good reasons.
It is very hot right now.
This there's an exodus of people leaving,
aid organizations really struggling,
a lack of water.
We've seen ourselves
here, intermittent connectivity,
trying to get
to speak to people on
the ground is incredibly hard.
And I know your parents went there
for a short amount of time,
right, to Sudan, never
seeing this coming. I want
They didn't see it coming.
As a matter of fact,
no one saw this coming,
which is extremely surprising
that no one was warned
that there was going to be a war
to break out and evacuate the country.
As soon as possible.
Typically, there's
at least a 24 hour notice
for people to figure out a way to escape.
And and they've gone through a lot
these past two weeks,
and they've made it this far.
We're hoping that they can just survive
and this ordeal can come to an end.
This nightmare can come to an end
for all of us.
Well, we're hoping that, too.
Please keep us posted in mind.
And Layla,
I hope, of course, that this interview
helps facilitate
at least the bureaucracy.
Get some your father some
help on the ground.
Please keep us posted.
Imad and Leila, keep us posted on
how he's doing
it'll will be wonderful to speak to him
when he's on the other side.
And he's caught his breath
and he's relaxed.
Thank you very much.
Keeping my fingers crossed for you.
Both appreciated.